[Music]
they want to make a deal so we'll see
what happens if they make it fun if they
don't make it that's fine president
Trump the commander in chief with a
unannounced visit to Afghanistan to
visit our troops to thank them for their
service being a long way from their
families on this all-american holiday
and also talking a bit about the big
picture for Afghanistan with that let's
bring in our panel
Susan preachy Oh chief congressional
correspondent for the Washington
Examiner our Madani White House reporter
for The Associated Press and Democratic
strategist Leslie Marshall Susan your
thoughts on the president turning up in
Afghanistan today real critical moment
clearly for the peace deal in
Afghanistan that has long eluded the
United States the president wants fewer
troops there they're about twelve
thirteen thousand troops he wants it
down to about 8,000 but you can't do
that if there's no peace deal and we
haven't been able to achieve that that
was all called off a couple months ago
with that explosion in Kabul killed an
American soldier the president said
forget it no more talks now he's saying
let's start again let's start this up
but it's still a real long road to get
from just talking to the American troops
leaving and I think the president is
becoming aware of the fact that if all
the troops leave the terror threat there
will build again potentially threatening
the United States it seems to me from
listening to him today he did make this
comment about total victory which I
don't think anyone really thinks it's
possible there right now but he did talk
about the idea of you know you know if
we get a deal fine if we don't that's
fine and if we don't that means the
troops are gonna stay there and I think
that's the message I got from the
president armored you covered the White
House commander-in-chief visiting the
troops on a holiday well first the
cloak-and-dagger of these things is
always really cool it seems impossible
like you're the idea oh that the
president's gonna visit this country and
fly-in into Afghanistan and no one's
gonna know about it but it kind of
happened that way which you know that
it's always I think kind of cool how
these visits come down the other part of
this that I think you're absolutely
right about is just how important this
is particularly going into 2020 and this
if you can get some sort of can get a
peace deal and start working towards a
drawdown
that's the sort of bumper sticker
foreign-policy moment that he needs as
he's going towards November Leslie your
thoughts on the images coming from
Afghanistan seeing President Trump with
the troops making them for their service
and give them a pat on the back as
they're a long way from their families
it's the right thing to do as commander
in chief whether a democrat or
republican and I think this is a
nonpartisan issue that I would give the
president a thumbs up on what I would
not give him a thumbs up on is hoping
that he can achieve any kind of a peace
deal with the Taliban you can't trust
them we've seen it before and when we
walked away from the table they said
look we're gonna start bombing people
killing people and they did just that
with what they did in Kabul so I I hope
that there can be some peace I would
agree it would be a feather in his
foreign Cal policy cap but I don't think
that's going to be possible but as
commander-in-chief visiting troops are
fighting for our freedoms on a day when
they're away from their families like I
said I'll give him a thumbs up on that
all right sticking with our foreign
policy theme here North Korea
perhaps wishing us a happy Thanksgiving
up - it's bad tricks take a listen to
the Japanese Prime Minister on North
Korea although we haven't confirmed
anything falling into our territory or
exclusive economic zone the frequent
launch of ballistic missiles by North
Korea is a serious challenge not only
for Japan but also for the international
community so Lesley are the North
Koreans not getting enough attention the
North Koreans are doing what they've
done regardless of the Republican or
president president being Republican or
Democrat in the United States in the
White House and the president now is
seeing what other presidents have in
recent day have been dealing with
whether it's Kim Jong on his father even
his grandfather which is unless we
removed troops from the Korean Peninsula
they're not going to stop what they're
doing is it a test isn't it a test we're
looking at super launchers here this is
a leader this is a nation not to be
trusted and we're seeing that not only
today but we've seen that we cannot be
calling this man or quite frankly this
nation our friend as the president so
frequently does honor this is a
relationship the president's put a lot
into trying to take a different approach
than other commanders in chief your
thoughts on North Korea at this point
this I think is a when he came into
office this was the most difficult and
dangerous position
on his the foreign-policy menu he faced
as he's going towards the end of his
first term it returns to being the most
difficult position he faces and I it's
tricky he went from fire and fury to
beautiful letters you can't go back to
fire and fury and kim jeong-hoon
he's not an idiot as the president has
pointed out as well he knows what's
going on with impeachment he knows
what's going on with an election and I
think he's gonna apply to pressure the
president Susan your thoughts with that
it's no one's talking about how
impeachment plays into all this makes it
really hard for the president to move on
a serious foreign policy initiative with
North Korea right now when he's being
undercut in America and the foot and all
foreign leaders know this and see this
everywhere around the world but this is
also a huge issue because the president
thought he could achieve this deal with
North Korea
then everybody knew North Korea it was
going to be impossible to denuclearize
them and they want the sanctions removed
they want troops to stop our troops to
stop holding exercises with South Korea
which has not happened so this is out of
frustration for that that the nuclear
talks are not restarting those sanctions
are still in place really hurting North
Korea and those joint military exercises
are still happening
therefore kim jeong-hoon is going to
keep up with these missile these
short-range missile Texas's on a
two-year university anniversary of the
ICBM launch there's going to be more of
this all right the hot topic number
three let's take a listen to some of the
people on the streets of Hong Kong the
silent majority expressed a voice by
their vote but there is still a long way
to go
it's the uphill battle we will continue
to fight until the day we get free
election and the victory of Hong Kong
okay so Hong Kong obviously quite happy
that the United States Congress passed
several bills standing up for people
there and really going against Beijing
the president signed it into law Susan
your thoughts on this issue well they
were celebrating today in Hong Kong
American flags photos of Trump very
excited that he signed the bill he
really didn't have much of a choice
though because it was passed nearly
unanimously in both the House in the
Senate which means they would easily
override a veto that is not a
all Trump wants to get into right now he
did signal he wasn't sure if he was
going to sign this in part because we're
trying to negotiate this big deal with
China on trade that's really his
priority I believe although he does
support the people of Hong Kong he was
kind of forced into signing this but it
certainly looks good for him right now
in Hong Kong I'm or what about that you
know trying to get a trade deal with
Beijing well what I guess the activity
that sort of surprised me is for the
unconventional president he is this was
a really conventional way to approach
this in a sort of slow walking at prayer
in the last six days and then Wednesday
night when you know most of Washington
was already tucked into Thanksgiving
announcing that he was signing this at
the end of the day though I think
there's too much at stake for both
Beijing and Washington to to do really
anything there's gonna be a real
retaliation you know they're having a
pork shortage right now they need
American farmers we have a December 15th
deadline going on that could affect
things like toys and our iPhones
American companies are concerned about
this as well all right let's bring in
Leslie with our remaining seconds on
this issue look you know regardless of
Wall Street and the stock market and
regardless of a trade deal which this
could hurt I'm actually surprised that
the president came to the table despite
the fact you had unanimous approval in
the Senate and only one Republican who
didn't in the house vote for this you're
seeing not only do our elected
politicians want this but America wants
this and we had to do this if we're
going to ring the bell of freedom and
democracy throughout the world this is
something as a leader and the leader of
the free world that the president had to
do but I'm surprised he didn't push back
more and I'm glad that he did this all
right quite a day in foreign policy
panel thanks very much